c'est non non une première
[Musique]
pierre desproges on m'a dit que vous
aviez un chien
les animaux extraordinaires de pierre
desproges avec naf naf gavage 4,6 on
tient mangeurs de graines spa chaîne de
chasse qui a peur des poules des lapins
mi-lourds le latin boxeur et enfin
joséphine la grenouille savante
cette poule est la mère des décès chien
en fait c'est simple c'est la mère du
petit celtel qui les approuvaient qui
les a élevés
vous avez vu donc ce chien prépetit al
jésus était tout petit il a été
abandonné par la mère qui était une
espagnole qui est partie d'ailleurs quel
chanteur espagnol et qui a laissé tomber
ses quatre petits et c'est cette poule
c'est adorable petite bête qui les a
recueillis se sont elles ce sont des
chiens complètement au poulet si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi
ils ne mangent que comme des poules
alors voyez où j'y jette le blé par
terre non elle lui préfère le le blé
dans la bouche directement c'est qu'en
local a gardé quelque chose du chien sud
mais c'est sur la talisman au régime
alors qu'une foule réclamant aux plantes
et voyez vous de l'élite le bec des
comptes en grec c'est un peu mou ça donc
ils mangent du grain ce n'est pas très
courant
le soir ils vont dans le sens large
comme si sa couche comme des poulets se
couche à 4h30 les l'hiver et vers 9
heures le était couchée 9,9 et
nourrissant de rendre tous les cinq dans
le poulailler
et puis c'est le chant du coq chien qui
les réveille un matin il ne compte pas
je tiens à préciser
on a beaucoup fabulé là-dessus aucun
chien détail capable de pondre en
revanche jeudi leur pouce des plumes au
dos derrière celui ci un vieux manteau
de laine qui cache bien ses plumes
c'est un set à chaque et qui est en fait
un gros pouce à un bon gros poussin
taureauvous synthois ils vont jours à
m'en aller
reste donc eu beaucoup au chien s'est
traduit mal préféré le chien ont
modérément le chien c'est le chien c'est
un pour moi c'est qu'une vague relations
ce soit l'amour en revanche l'animal
chère à mon coeur c'est le cochon je
crois vraiment en réalité qu'est le
cochon est la plus noble conquête de
l'homme avec la femme fasse surtout le
cochon syfy ainsi si vous voulez me
suivre dans la porcherie je vais vous
montrer au guichet pour souvent jeune et
je l'apprends 150 cochon sur moi jama
porcherie
[Musique]
alors là vous avez je le dis en toute
modestie l'une des plus belles
collections de cochon d'humour essayé
certaines pièces qui datent tous deux
mois qui entourent trois siècles d'âge
certaines sont en or massif celle ci est
en platine ont parmi ceux ci
je tiens tout particulièrement à ces
cochons qui sont tous les quatre qui
appartiennent tous les quatre à la
grande famille des cochons de béatrice
poterne la grande dessinatrice anglaise
qui m'en a fait cadeau au cours d'un
après-midi que j'ai passé avec elle dans
une meule dans un an dans une auberge
des campagnes britannique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
e
bon par ailleurs vous avez ici des
cochons noble tous de noble extraction
qui ont énormément souffert de la
révolution française
[Musique]
c'était très dur pour ça non mais ça
c'est une sacrée [ __ ] quant à cette
pièce que voici
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
étonnant il s'agit d'un gorrec qui me
vient de hollande ça pays où les gorets
sont rares le banc des digues ce qui est
créé deux temps sa valeur est alors
chose étonnante encore plus c'est que
dans ce cochon qui me vient d'amsterdam
quand on met une pièce de monnaie dedans
riez vous dans le port d'amsterdam ya
des marins qui chantent
[Musique]
pardon pardon c'est moi c'est pas cuit 1
ce lapin c'est un tout c'est moi j'aime
bien les bêtes en général sa tablette
chez moi là vous avez un lapin à côté
d'un chien de chasse est inscrite
étonnant c'est que voyez l'attitude du
chêne chasse quand il est pas dans la
nature par rapport à la base c'est
complètement différent relais plutôt
tendance à sauver et ce lapin quand on
le laisse avec le chien il se met sur
son petit derrière et ils filent des
gifles aux chiens c'est pour ça que je
suis obligé de tenir parce que c'est un
chien non cette voyez vous l'attitude
d'un chêne chasse en face d'un lapin
dans un appartement
c'est très curieux enfin écoutez on va
pas trop s'attarder sur les lapins parce
que moi ce qui m'intéresse vraiment si
les cochons
l'état s'est borné pour le les choses de
la vie
mais elle a quand même une qualité qui
est exceptionnel chez les grenouilles
c'est que fifine ses comptes et je vais
vous l'avez dressé à compter l ses
comptes et elle sait faire des
opérations simples évidemment je ne
doute pas des racines carrées parce que
la lamelle n'a pas encore déjeuné dans
quel un petit peu faibles d'esprit mais
enfin un peu quand même
on va essayer de voir repris alors à 1
c'est la réponse finale c on va
compliquer un peu voir trois de
pipelines 3 et 2 même si oui c'est ça
aussi mais on va compliquer un peu alors
si c'est un bon six mois-un an plus tôt
ah ça c'est difficile fifine c'est une
soustraction six mois-un la petite heure
oui de l'abeille et vous pouvez re poser
la question plus lentement alors le 6 -
1 6 mois zafy fine c'est bien parce que
l'effort ton histoire de france voulait
qu'elle vous donne la date de la date de
la bataille de marignan la date de la
bataille de marignan fifine la date de
la bataille de marignan aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non